I'm not let go all right well don't let
it go but I do want to say first of all
congratulations and I think this is a
movie that is so important at this time
in our country and so it really is
something that everyone should see if
they haven't seen but did you understand
the undertaking and what you were making
when you started this journey now and
now look at it today did you understand
do I need to talk to that unless we will
never hear you unless we'll never hear
you I think we did know what we you know
that it was something significant but
and we knew we wanted to get it right
and I'll tell you one thing nobody in
town wanted to make it until these two
guys and Linda jumped on board mm-hmm
and still we had no studio and yet it
all came together and it's their belief
in this project and Octavia's that
carried the day and that's the truth
like this movie wouldn't have gotten
made except that they believed in it
right there the chemistry between you
two is incredible but I want to know
this at what point did you stop eating
Vigo what dear boy what point did you
put the food down because you did
something you did some things with food
that I've never seen before and it was
less fun going the other way but it was
great she was deathly ill well she was
like already nausea so what I'd be
talking to her the sauces in my mouth
rehearsal oh so many people had don't
know about dr. Shirley and now after
this movie he is someone that they are
searching out and learning about what
did it mean to represent a man like that
a hero who was a hidden hero I think I
feel this the same way as I do about dr.
Shirley as I do about the green book in
itself and that you know this film has
become a talking point a starting point
for people to be able to take their
their research and understanding of it
further and of course those who already
are familiar with it it's it's and and
familiar with dr. Shirley then they
already they already know that but so
many people haven't been exposed to him
and his genius and and just the man and
I'm honored to just have an opportunity
to step in his shoes and for a short
period of time for a moment in his life
and get to tell that story alongside of
me go as Tony Bella longer yeah and by
the way how good does it feel to have
that golden glow because you're holding
it like a shoulder surgery afterwards
but but I'm good no it's the surgery
right yeah yeah and this is like you
know this is you can't do this by
yourself like this brother pushed me
every single day and was so supportive
and every days when there was days when
I didn't feel like I really had it
either either physically or mentally and
and and how I got there me personally
was because of him and and and Pete and
so I I know so much of this to vigo so
I'm very very grateful thank you brother
I want to ask you about those who have
criticized the movie because I was
shocked to read some of the criticisms
or people saying oh this is whitewashed
racism it makes it palatable for
everybody what are you saying how do you
respond to those those people please
please Octavia please give the mic to
someone who is been under attack listen
I never I'm gonna this is probably gonna
be controversial but I don't follow
negative energy
I can only answer what drew me to this
project and hopefully that will change
some hearts and minds and for me it was
about the fact that I have been a part
of movies where there were white saviors
and where we didn't have agency and I
thought dr. shirlee story an
african-american man affluent educated
powerful beautiful elegant the fact that
he had agency and he had the connections
that he had and he decided he could have
taken the easy route and just went on a
metropolitan tour but he decided to hire
Tony Val illunga
to take him through the deep south that
meant something it means something today
and I think it's an important thing no
one was doing he chose to do that every
other black artists had a black driver
exactly Don Shurley was was people off
gave a little based and progressive and
and doing something really brave so
anyway so so for those people who feel
that he was a magical Negro hmm he was
magic he was very man he was magic so
that's what I say to that and Nick what
does it mean to you to see this story
come to light and tonight I saw you
standing up there what were you thinking
about after the movie has announced in
the wind I was think about my parents
and I just want to say everyone here
took so much was meticulous from the
writing of the script so the story
people on a pond on the screen to the
actors to participation and and my
hearse Allah Himself so we came to talk
to Shirley we took so much care to make
sure this was right we did with love and
respect for him throughout the whole
thing
his betrayal is magnificent and
beautiful credible and what's incredible
if there's any negative I feel terrible
about that because it all came from up
from love and I'll say this dr. Shirley
approved everything that's in the script
and they would think she did not want so
it wasn't a full bio of him was the
story of him on the trip with my father
he approved that and we tried to to
honor that and respect it and I think
his name was out there in the world
he's portrayed magnificently yep and it
was an honor to do that and I think we
all cared so much every part of it and
he really was on top of everything
listen you made a movie that people are
proud to see then when you leave the
theater and you're proud of that movie
you've done something well
congratulations you guys
[Music]